[Music]
you know what a Harlequin is the
Harlequins role is to serve it's nothing
without a master no one gives two shits
who we are beyond that
the Joker and I broke up did a fresh
start but it turns out I wasn't the only
daemon got them looking for emancipation
ocular new screen to cost me
[Applause]
who are you guys
[Music]
you're still quick
you need
after all the bus now
we should order pizzas
[Applause]
[Music]
who's having a good time
you psycho chick could never call a
woman chick I'll accept fraud lady woman
but on occasion [ __ ] eh please how to
move that for anyway
oh [ __ ] oh come on man you could get
that buffed out no you can get that
buffed out
mm knock and talk
Oh hands behind your head right now I
got this I'm gonna penetrate this man's
soul with my heart what watch sir I
realized that you scared you know
sometimes how deep you think you got in
your soul I'm done my own petard oh oh
here we go again he wants your legacy to
be muscle shirts and body counts do all
this you didn't shoot anybody come on
Kevin you know I shot some yeah [ __ ] me
nice trees I never trusted anybody I'm
asking you man
bad boys one last time last time but not
just black with cops - we'll pull
ourselves over later
we will write about the gun I've been
tellin ya for a year he can't [ __ ] Mike
he's a like HP
bad boys bad boys whatcha gonna do what
you gonna do when we call no never
y'all will never do that again yeah and
you [ __ ] up the lyrics which take a
long time to learn
[Music]
the call over there you really ruining
my slow right now you know that got an
issue
this movement man
[Music]
we have 15 minutes it's time
hit it hello boys
or if I told you I know what happens
when you die
you become a ghost
by more criminal records no more office
parties are stupid weddings that's part
of being dead is the freedom
not policies or politics no one touch is
mine
we answer to no one you can take out
some truly evil people
[Music]
okay
[Music]
these people would declare today none of
us will be remembered it's about to
happen we'll do things honey raise the
better ones right who the hell are you
for no one
if they exist they can be made not
fighter jets
you see
sorry for yelling welcome to the world's
biggest magnet
[Music]
I know this road work I mean I wasn't
sure sure had a suspicion but I got no
this is all so [ __ ] dangerous
I wait to play a game with me ray I
don't want to play a game oh please no I
said play a game with me right Minh
right badly I want you to imagine a
character your boss Mickey
piss you're too smart to be blackmailing
us Fletcher hey sweet Mary Jane is my
vice your boys on the other hand is and
always has been a destroyer of world
you're out of touch and I would like you
to consider an offer I am NOT for sale
the plot begins to thicken now I can't
be specific about the heroes and zero
but how a protagonist is a hungry animal
there is a lot of money hanging in the
balance our antagonist explodes on a
seed back a millennial FireWire and has
indirectly started a war I think you
need to see this faster
[Music]
they find it make an inquiry his name is
[ __ ] we spoke with a PA says housing
[ __ ]
please sorry for whole condo [ __ ] if you
smell smoke it's because there's a fire
out quickly these people are gonna clean
house and you are part of that house in
the jungle only way a lion survives not
by acting like
oh it's really warming up now is
before the lies hungry
[Music]
/ associates or not so you killed
someone no it was the gravity that
killed him it's been 10 years since the
zombie apocalypse just functional family
very do you know what I would like I
don't give a [ __ ] what she might have
survived by using their wish for [ __ ]
nothing personal how could that not be
personal that's like my whole thing yeah
you're right it was personal on October
18 what made you do it
and don't say descriptive can this be
just between us drugs cost money didn't
see that coming right you'll be the
first to die I like your enthusiasm
you might die yeah thank you for your
sacrifice from the directly advance
PETA right oh yes
and white who's a dick Casablancas Oh
God well I think I would have made a
damn fine president I think those cigars
were left over from the Clinton
administration Academy Award nominee
what are you Harrelson let's kick some
dick I mean award nominee Jesse
Eisenberg right now right now Academy
Award nominee Abigail Breslin
boom Academy Award winner Emma Stone
Zombieland double-check or shut up
that sings very 2009
30-plus years of service combat medals
citations only man to shoot down three
enemy planes in last 40 years yet you
can't get a promotion won't retire
despite your best efforts you've refused
to die
[Music]
you should be at least a two-star
admiral by now yet here you are captain
what is that it's one of life's
mysteries sir
[Music]
[Music]
the end is inevitable maverick you kind
of set it for extinction
maybe so sir but not today
we're not be a Guana
I asked those two yes can you know
either me simply you're not bah
Hey yes even let's go we're running late
better solar beam up is are easier see
Juana's cincuenta daniela Ramos
[Music]
that is not your father come with me or
you're dead minutes thirty seconds
hey my monkey no chemica Democrat but it
busted
why are you Kenny you're my mission
[Music]
where's that my name is Sarah Connor I
hunt terminators enough of a resume for
you
how do we stop this thing
I'm going to help you change the future
I'm done running I'm gonna spend and
fight
you can't dive in you if you don't make
it
everybody dies why not just let me have
it because we're not machines
metal mother
[Music]
this will not be a war of heroes which
is all to see this is going to be fun
the world burns you have no idea of what
men are capable of we must do something
I know you want to fight
but there are other ways of doing your
duty you're going to need a suit come on
we are the first independent
intelligence agency preserving peace and
protecting life welcome to the club
like witches at black masses while
government's wait for orders our people
take action
minds and blood destruction though it's
time to shut a lot
[Music]
captain structure
My dear
[Music]
our enemies think we are gentlemen
but reputation is what people think of
you
character is what you are
I'm ready yes
[Music]
but ready we shall see
this is called a parachute it means that
one can jump out of a plane safely
[Applause]
ah you please stop bothering like him so
Arthur I have some bad news for you this
is the last time we'll be meeting you
don't listen dear you just ask the same
questions every week how's your job are
you having any negative thoughts all I
have are negative thoughts
and finally in a world where everyone
thinks they could do my job check out
this guy
when I was a little boy and told people
I was gonna be a comedian everyone
laughed at me well no one's laughing now
you can say that again
[Music]
so awful isn't it
[Music]
for my own life
if I even really existed
but I do
starting to notice
I think this is funny
there's a joke to you
very one small thing yeah when you bring
me out can you introduce me as Joker
[Music]
send a
the cloud
[Music]
we passed on all we know
[Music]
a thousand generations to the noona
[Music]
but this is your fight
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
taught you that
yes it's in
[Music]
[Music]
David oh man I think women can do
anything just because they can doesn't
mean they should
[Music]
just a decrease that that's just the way
out standing angels you have the new
client who is she I can't sleep at night
I'm the lead programmer on a product
that can revolutionize the power
industry but there is a possibility it
can be weaponized ulema want you to know
I'm Jay
who are you
embossing
welcome to the pounds of agencies we
exist because traditional law
enforcement can't keep up I don't like
them boy you guys are like lady spies
thanks former mi6 oh god what did you do
to spend my compressed his carotid and
deoxygenated his brainstem that sounds
painful don't worry he's gonna wake up
unless he doesn't Sabina runs the ground
game channel stuff let's get the weapon
before it becomes every bad guys
favorite new toy take her to the closet
cheer her up we're gonna need some wigs
[Music]
we're still in the first closet there's
another closet stop touching some of
these blows up
[Music]
June are you flirting with a handsome
nerd
[Music]
how'd that feel because it looked like
it felt really good I felt nice
[Music]
good morning angels morning charlie
[Music]
still talking to you French it's
complicated
many a dear when we first got together
we were different people
[Music]
grandpa hey Anthony this is a Martha and
Bethany the suspense grandfather meet
you morning sort of bargain on you
you're not barging he's barging my
little Walker yeah did you guys see
Spencer Vicki went back in we gotta go
get him
huh what who are you
oh my god you're Spencer's grandfather
are we in Florida thank you my little
walk look did I die and turn into some
kind of a small muscular boy scout are
we dead it sure feels good now look at
my thighs okay you have some issues here
the game is busted lose the game I'm not
yet I'm wonder you welcome to Jumanji
the sniffs vet joke is even more
challenging and remember future of
Jumanji is in your hands I have one
important question who is Jumanji is
that Bubba's boy well we did our we
inhale
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what the fellows to suit your strengths
and weaknesses smoldering intensity it's
this stupid face you make huh
he's gonna know you having a heart
attack breathe breathe this whole left
side is shutting down
you